bonjour je suis valérie shafer est ma
recherche porte sur l'histoire française
du web dans les années 90
[Musique]
il y à peine 20 ans fin 96 jacques
chirac en visite à la bibliothèque
françois-mitterrand s'étonne face à une
souris d'ordinateur ce qui suscite de
savoureux moments sur le mulot guignols
de l'info mais véhicule aussi l'idée que
les politiques ne comprennent pas
grand-chose à l'informatique
mais ce ne sont pas les seuls beaucoup
de français n'ont pas d'ordinateurs
personnels ignore encore tout d'internet
et du web en 1996 en tous les cas une
certitude ce soir tout le monde parle
d'internet mais la plupart ne savent pas
exactement de quoi il s'agit alors en
schématisant disons qu internet est un
super minitel qui permet d'accéder à des
millions et des millions de service même
hésitation dans les médias où l'on parle
parfois de super minitel tandis que côté
fournisseurs d'accès internet et
éditeurs de services un modèle
économique mais aussi un public reste à
trouver
et pourtant dans les coulisses on
assiste à une effervescence à ce moment
charnière où se joue l'adoption de la
toile en france celle ci ne se fait pas
sans débat alors qu'éclatent les
premiers procès pour contenus à
caractère raciste ou pédophile ce réseau
néo nazis n'est malheureusement pas
isolé d'une manière générale la liberté
pratiquement totale qui règne sur
internet qui se joue des frontières
permettent de créer des réseaux qui
peuvent se révéler donc très très
dangereux mais travaux sur l'histoire
française du web dans les années 90
montre un chantier foisonnant en
construction comme ces juifs qui
peuplaient alors la toile
loin de l'image une révolution brutale
le web est en effet une construction
patiente faite de tâtonnements et
notamment ceux des internautes
ma recherche les suit dans leurs
premières navigations depuis le son du
modem
les bugs les hotlines la découverte des
cybercafés ou encore des annuaires et
des pages perso de multiples sources
permettent de retracer cette histoire du
web en société guide de l'internet
entretiens oraux articles de presse mode
d'emploi des kits de connexion sans
oublier le riche fonds d'archivés
audiovisuelles conserver à li na
et puis il ya les archives des listes de
discussion et les archives du web
lui-même que nous continuons d'explorer
collectivement au sein d'un projet qui
s'intitule web 90 car le chantier la
fouille qui s'ouvre pour l'historien
sont immenses
cette recherche n'a en effet de cesse de
questionner l'histoire mais aussi son
écriture
dès 1996 la fondation internet arxiv a
commencé archivées
webb avant que cette mission ne soit
confiée en france à la bnf et alina dans
le cadre du dépôt légal
face aux archives du web l'historien re
devient pleinement artisans il doit
façonner son objet mais tim berners lee
le créateur du web ne disait il pas déjà
dans une interview de 1999 qu internet
et le web se devait d'être considérés
comme de l'argile plutôt qu'une
sculpture que l'on observerait à
distance bon endroit
[Musique]